retrouvez manger ses voté
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]
salut moussaillon il y a du vent dans
les verres on se croise sur le pont d'un
bâton manger ses beautés vous accueille
à Noirmoutier à la pointe de la fosse
face aux continents et aujourd'hui on va
visiter cette île de Noirmoutier en
compagnie du sénateur Bruno Retailleau
président de son groupe les républicains
au Sénat ils m'attend pas très loin
d'ici au fameux passage du Gois allez je
remonte le vent
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le taillot
je suis passé mais juste hein
ce passage qui va du continent à l'île
de Noirmoutier ça a été longtemps la
seule voie d'accès la seule le pont a
été inauguré au milieu des années 70 et
donc le seul lieu de passage qui relie à
ni de Noirmoutier au continent cette
voix et là on voit que la marée remonte
ça va très vite et dans une demi-heure
la route sera recouverte bon alors
direction Noirmoutier avant de se faire
rattraper par les eaux parce qu'on parle
souvent du Mont-Saint-Michel avec les
marais qui remontent mais là c'est bien
pareil
sauver des eaux
alors là on arrive sur l'île de
Noirmoutier
c'est c'est une surface assez grande
quand même il y a combien il y a 30 km
en longueur
les deux tiers de la surface sont en
dessous du niveau de la mer ce qui fait
que au cours des âges il y a eu des dips
qui ont été tracés d'ailleurs on le voit
bien là avec les rocks qui permettent de
défendre l'île contre la mer et il faut
refaire ses travaux très régulièrement
[Musique]
comment est-ce que vous êtes engagé dans
la voie politique à partir de cette âme
vendéenne moi j'ai pas venu en fait à la
politique par un parti j'ai suivi par un
lieu par mon territoire la Vendée
j'habite toujours dans la commune je
suis né
l'autre côté c'est la Vendée des hauts
vocales ça c'est une petite poitrine à
partir de laquelle je voulais servir
aussi la grande patrie parce que mon
grand-père dès 14 il était engagé pour
la première guerre mondiale et une balle
allemande lui a traversé la gorge et
j'ai eu ce sentiment d'avoir cette dette
là
des générations avaient dû servir la
France et je laisse absolument tout
servir mon pays donc ma petite patrie
aussi est-ce que vous vous sentez bien
au Sénat est-ce que le Sénat est une
chambre qui correspond à votre façon
d'être totalement j'étais député donc
j'ai pu aussi comparer l'Assemblée
nationale est plus tumultueuse alors
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est même
beaucoup plus que ça et c'est beaucoup
trop parce que malheureusement le jeu
des parties que concernant l'Assemblée
nationale est sur un calendrier
présidentiel donc elle a été au cours de
la présidente
sismique c'est-à-dire que les beaucoup
députés désormais sont élus parce que
ils mettent sur leur affiche électoral
la photo du président de la République
mais c'est pas le même tempérament aussi
plus éloigné des médias et que on aime
le travail de fond aussi et on est la
chance des territoires et quand je vous
parlais de Racine je pense que on peut
pas comprendre la France sans comprendre
sa diversité ici par exemple en Vendée
on a une puissance économique
extraordinaire et croyez moi on a des
entreprises familiales où les gens sont
très associés tout simplement chef
d'entreprise parce qu'ils ont grandi sur
le vent des mêmes écoles ils ont joué
sur les mêmes terrains de foot on peut
pas maintenir un modèle social généreux
si on crée pas de la richesse
et j'entends que vous aimez la politique
vous n'êtes pas un déçu de la politique
vous aimez l'histoire
j'aime l'histoire j'aime la géographie
moi je me suis retrouvé là je me
souviens c'était il y a bien longtemps
au moment d'Erika et moi je me suis
battu pendant pratiquement 15 ans pour
faire passer cette idée du préjudice
écologique
dans le Code civil dans le droit de la
réparation pollueur payeur voilà c'est
pas un écolo qu'il a fait c'est moi
l'écologie la nature l'amour de
l'environnement je le vis tous les jours
vous avez pas que j'ai un petit peu les
écolos des villes ceux qui sont des
penseurs écologiques mais qui ne sont
pas beaucoup dans la campagne j'épingle
tout simplement les faux écologistes il
parle de tout son écologie ils veulent
déconstruire les hommes et ils veulent
qu'on arrête ton barbecue ils veulent
déjeuner les co-récations et l'écologie
là-dedans donc moi je note que sur le
plan du barbecue vous êtes en accord
avec Fabien Roussel il est parti
communiste
des communistes de l'année je pense
qu'il faut reconstruire la politique sur
des bases qui soient saines à partir des
idées à partir des convictions à partir
d'une sincérité ce qu'attendre de nous
les Français pourquoi est-ce que les
Français croient la politique c'est
parce qu'ils pensent que les hommes et
les femmes politiques ne pas sincère
c'est ce que c'est ce que les gens je
crois en vie de d'entendre on peut leur
dire des choses qui parfois ne leur
plaisent pas mais ils veulent ils
veulent cette sincérité et cette
droiteure je crois que la droiture pour
comme projet pour la droite c'est pas
mal non ça va bien on va aller chercher
la sincérité ensemble à Noirmoutier si
vous le voulez bien il y a un nouveau
seigneur tout enréolé de ces trois
étoiles au guide Michelin Alexandre
couillon qui nous a préparé quelques
beaux légumes dans son potager
après cette petite escapade potagère et
culinaire dans le nouveau spot
gastronomique de l'île nous irons
récolter les pommes de terre avec Rudy
et sa famille la pomme de terre et puis
ensuite on ira chercher les moules de
Sébastien et Véronique directement sur
la barge au milieu des bouchons et on
terminera sur le continent visiter les
éleveurs de canards de chalands car le
canard de Chalon c'est important en
Vendée et avec la grippe aviaire c'est
pas simple ces jours-ci allez en route
le chef est au jardin le chef est au
jardin bonjour Alexandre vous allez bien
et vous-même super très bien ça va c'est
formidable qu'est-ce que c'est c'est des
fèves ça on est en plein dans les fèves
on voit quelques petites gousses qui
arrivent mais il va falloir entendre un
petit peu encore la vie du cuisinier
elle commence quand même dans le potager
en tout cas ici elle démarre entre le
potager et la crier c'est le début d'une
journée et on est tributaire de ce
jardin et de l'océan et c'est le potager
qui fait la carte on se doit pour nous
d'écrire cette carte au quotidien
d'aller voir l'océan tous les matins se
baser sur les conditions météorologiques
de se dire bah non aujourd'hui il y aura
pas les petits pois Estelle et
zarabassés un tout petit peu ce matin on
va faire un service il y en aura pas
pour ce soir dans deux jours on en aura
et puis ainsi de suite pourquoi ce petit
poids aujourd'hui il est bon pourquoi
parce que il a été ramassé il est pas
passé dans les champs froides il a été
cuisiné dans l'instantané au service du
midi
et demain on racontera une autre
histoire ici on est à l'airbaudière
l'Herbaudière c'est le bout de
Noirmoutier Noirmoutier c'est le bout de
la Vendée la Vendée c'est le bois
Occident ad des bouts occidentaux de la
France et donc de l'Europe pour faire
venir les gens trois étoiles ça va
peut-être tout changer non ça a déjà
beaucoup changé mais mais avec déjà
connu et il vient de le dire il a parlé
de la mère avec la criée puis de la
terre et la Vendée pour virer comprendre
c'est le grand large c'est la mer c'est
le Vendée Globe c'est les grands
horizons et puis c'est aussi la terre et
quand on est cuisinier on exalte la
terre le terroir alors c'est vrai que de
voir une telle diversité de légumes
Alexandre couillon ici au milieu des
pommes de terre qui sont partout je suis
sûr que le paysan noir moutrain lui il
s'attache à sa pomme de terre et qu'il
en démord pas trop c'est vrai mais bon
quand on revient un petit peu en arrière
moi je vais le souvenir de mon
grand-père qui avait son petit lopin de
terre il était marin patate c'est à dire
qu'il faisait la culture de la pomme
pour les appeler
il a troqué quelques légumes lors de la
saison estivale et puis sinon bah il
vivait aussi de sa pêche et nous il y a
quelques années on s'est dit mais on est
obligé d'aller chercher ces légumes hors
de l'île et je dis c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible bien sûr la pomme de
terre ok super mais moi je pense que
l'avenir il va falloir faire du légume
du légume diversifié faire tourner les
cultures à petit échelle mais on peut
faire du qualitatif
[Musique]
alors là on a les petits radis qu'on a
rapporté du jardin alors vous noterez
quand même ce sénateur que on a laissé
les radicelles ça c'est vraiment la
cuisine moderne parce qu'il y a encore 5
ans on les aurait plus chez mais
maintenant il faut garder les racines
mais en fait en fin de compte on sait
exactement d'où ils arrivent alors on
sait ce qu'ils ont ils ont puisé on sait
qu'aujourd'hui la fan si on imagine par
exemple cette fan de la passer
simplement dans un bouillon de légumes
ou cuisent les carottes par exemple mais
on sait que tout est comestible parce
qu'on sait ce qui est ce qu'il a mangé
sera dit et regardez cette belle couleur
bien sûr c'est bon juste blanchi mixer
une petite noix de beurre une échalote
fondue un tout petit peu de crème nous
on part du principe que de la racine aux
légumes de la feuille jusqu'à la fleur
tout se mange je vais le prendre cuit
moi je vous laisse cru j'ai un peu un
palais d'acier moi
on va les servir avec un macro juste
grillé et on a la betterave le maquereau
le radis c'est cette cuisine de
l'instant et de l'instinct du quotidien
suivant le potager et l'arrivage des
bateaux et si je me retrouvais parce que
j'en ai pas vu dans votre jardin des
pommes de terre allez voir Rudy ah ouais
ouais
c'est pas loin vous allez voir ils sont
en plein dedans
[Musique]
ils sont en train de récolter là bien
sûr là c'est le pomme de terre de
Noirmoutier une pomme de terre primeur
la meilleure au monde c'est la gloire de
Noirmoutier
bonjour
agriculteur de mer en fils formidable
sur cinq générations
c'est beau hein donc ça c'est la mer on
appelle la mère c'est celle qu'on plante
c'est celle qui va donner donc les
tubercules et les autres patates il y en
a combien pour une patate planter ça
varie de 5 à 10
ça fait une grippe
et ça c'est la fierté ma fierté ma c'est
plutôt rond c'est une chair qui est
plutôt blanche pomme de terre ronde et
blanche et c'est la première c'est bien
fait en premier
elle est pas mal rissolée elle est pas
mal avec tout elle est elle est pas mal
tout court
la croisière de la pomme de terre
[Musique]
les Noirs
tout seul il est bien dressé il est bien
dressé hein
combien de temps ça dure la saison de
récolte de la pomme de terre ici trois
quatre mois de plantation et trois
quatre mois de récoltes vous bossez bien
monsieur sénateur on voit que
[Musique]
une coopérative de pomme de terre c'est
pour ça ah oui
il y a aussi le pont d'arrêt donc c'est
les pêcheurs et donc ces quatre
coopératives elle travaillait ensemble
sous la marque et l'image de Noirmoutier
en fait voilà s'appelle les saveurs de
l'île et en même temps c'est une
solidarité c'est-à-dire que les
producteurs sont pas les pêcheurs etc
les Soliers sont pas laissés seuls et ça
permet de mutualiser en fait les moyens
de promotion
et la bonne note à Noirmoutier qui est
un peu l'image de marque parce que c'est
le charisme ça représente combien de la
production à la coque un gros de 2% 3%
c'est vraiment l'aristocratie le haut du
panier c'est la crème
ce sénateur il y a mieux que mettre la
main à la pâte c'est mettre la main à la
patate à la patate bah bien sûr et on a
la patate en Vendée
[Musique]
bon monsieur de sénateur le temps change
vite à un Noirmoutier c'est
extraordinaire d'ailleurs
qu'il pleut de temps en temps parce
qu'on a besoin de plus aussi pour avoir
les pommes de terre nouvelles et
carrément et là on va aller se mettre à
l'abri à l'école du coup alors on va à
l'école mais on va surtout voir une
cuisine centrale qui approvisionne 300
enfants trois écoles une crèche avec des
circuits courts ici à
Noirmoutier-en-l'Île exactement
Sébastien donc chef cuisinier ça sent
bon quand on rentre chez vous merci ça
sent le poisson je mets le bon poisson
frais poisson
localise
et qu'est-ce que c'est comme poisson la
qui est en train de dire aujourd'hui ici
c'est une cuisine c'est le sénateur me
disait qui sert à la fois école
fraîche et centre de loisirs le mercredi
donc à peu près 300 enfants voilà et
Sébastien vous vous êtes en liaison
froide ils ont chaudes en liaison chaude
donc on fait la production le matin et à
10h30 on part livré dans les satellites
en fait donc on part on fait la crèche
et puis les trois écoles Franck est-ce
qu'il y a une tentation à un moment
donné de concéder la restauration à des
grands groupes de restauration
collective il y a eu une réflexion c'est
sûr parce que on veut regrouper parce
qu'on veut que ça coûte moins cher et il
y a eu vraiment une volonté des élus un
moment donné de dire stop on reste en
cuisine centrale on reste en Lison
chaude les parents ils sont très
attentifs ils sont vraiment très
soucieux de cette qualité de prestation
évidemment le sénateur c'est un peu le
chef de fil du local une certaine
manière bien sûr parce que le Sénat
c'est l'assemblée des territoires
Gambetta avait eu une phrase très belle
il y avait dit le Sénat c'est
l'assemblée des communes de France et ça
reste l'assemblée des territoires de
français donc nous on se bat pour le
local d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est que Sébastien est aussi soigné il
a je crois une vingtaine de yeets donc
il s'est parfaitement ce que produire
local veut dire et quand un chef
cuisinier est lui-même un producteur
local bah on lui fait pas la leçon
qu'est-ce que ça coûte ici le ticket
moyen des poly famille là maintenant on
a mis en place le quotient familial donc
on a des familles qui payent 80 centimes
ah ouais un seul minimum ça ça c'est le
minimum 1 euro et le plus c'est 2 euros
70 malgré l'inflation parce que la
volonté c'est vraiment que la grande
majorité des enfants mange à la
restauration scolaire mais les produits
locaux c'est vrai que c'est
gagnant-gagnant parce que les enfants
mangent mieux les familles sont
heureuses les producteurs locaux c'est
vraiment génial pour eux et puis je
trouve que même pour le personnel c'est
quand même beaucoup plus motivant
travailler une belle matière première
que des trucs qui viennent dont ces os
et qui sont congelés surgelés et alors
si je comprends bien la ce container
isotherme c'est prêt à partir c'est ça
c'est prêt à partir comme de terre de
Noirmoutier j'attends que ça moi je vous
le dis carrément
beurre blanc moi je sais pas pour vous
mais moi je vous très bien le le poisson
au beurre blanc là je suis ah ouais
alors je manque un petit peu de beurre
blanc chef je vous le dis il y a Vincent
qui arrive ce matin faut faire un stock
de beurre blanc j'ai fini le secondaire
donc j'ai le droit j'ai le droit d'avoir
du rhum du rap de blanc blanc
ah bah voilà
[Musique]
franchement voilà
si je devais trouver une raison de
retourner à l'école j'en ai peut-être
une là
[Musique]
je vois qu'on est attendu bonjour et
maman d'embarquée exactement bonjour
Sébastien
bonjour Sébastien
[Musique]
Sébastien ici on est au milieu des
bouchots là oui on est au milieu des
bouchons de au large du bois de la
chaise à Noirmoutier
il mange mais dans des quantités
incroyables industrielles
on en trouve quelques-unes dans dans nos
moules mais c'est très rare on en a pas
beaucoup peut-être parce que l'araignée
est préfère des fonds rocheux non on ne
sait pas pourquoi c'est
peut-être dur au climat et au terroir
peut-être que c'est plus là où on s'est
pas con pourquoi non plus elles sont
arrivées en Bretagne et pas ici en
Vendée alors dès que je me demandais
s'il y a au fond
[Musique]
on pouvait en vivre uniquement de la
moule ou est-ce que c'est pas mieux de
faire un peu d'huître quand même aussi
alors on peut en vivre quand il y a un
bon marché que les prix sont corrects
nous on s'aperçoit que depuis la fin de
l'année dernière ça devient difficile
que que de vivre d'un métier de
passionné comme ça ben ça devient
compliqué
à savoir est-ce que tout l’ostréiculture
la conchiliculture la mythiliculture et
prévue à disparaître en France je sais
pas à cause de quoi uniquement des lois
du marché ou à cause des lois et puis on
a pas chaud
de pas augmenter nos prix nous cette
année par rapport aux consommateurs
parce que tout augmente et qu'on se dit
qu'il faut quand même
et c'est les charges les charges bah
chaque courrier chaque courrier j'ai
envie de vous dire de l'URSSAF est un
noeud au ventre en plus je nous notre
salaire on l'a divisé par deux pour on
se dit que c'est qu'une mauvaise c'est
une mauvaise façade ça va revenir on va
réussir à sortir la tête de l'eau un peu
après on aime ce qu'on fait pour le
moment on aime ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
bon ben voilà que je passe le pont j'ai
laissé le sénateur Retailleau sur l'île
en train de déguster les moules de
Sébastien et Véronique et moi je dois
aller sur le continent du côté de
Challans parce que il y a une icône de
la gastronomie vendéenne c'est le canard
de chaland et je vais rencontrer un
éleveur mais depuis un an avec la grippe
aviaire il est pas la fête
alors Ingrid Burgot vous êtes avec votre
sœur à la tête de la maison Burgault
alors vous êtes les spécialistes d'un
canard particulier parce que le canard
de Chalon contrairement à la majorité
qui sont des canards gras des canards à
foie gras mais ici on fait du canard à
rôtir nous on fait du canard à rôtir
effectivement avec une particularité
chez nous c'est le canard au sang on
pratique un abattage de au canard n'est
pas saigné donc on parle de canard au
sang le sang restant à l'intérieur de la
viande et de la chair qui est la
célébrité dans ce régale les clients de
la Tour d'Argent notamment depuis des
années oui ça fait plus de 70 ans qu'on
fournit la maison effectivement bonjour
bonjour Dominique enchanté jean gris ça
va bien oui
mais alors je me pose une question tout
de suite pourquoi ne sont-ils pas dans
les champs alors nous sommes toujours en
période de grippe aviaire bien quoi
encore mais ça fait un an théoriquement
il y en avait plus mais c'est le
principe de précaution nous on les
laisse enfermer dans les bâtiments pour
éviter tout contact avec les oiseaux de
l'extérieur les canards sauvages les
oies les mouettes qui pourraient
recontaminer les animaux c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on les élèves en bâtiment
du coup ils sont là du coup ils sont là
on va avancer les voir bah oui oui bien
sûr ah bah ils sont jeunes l'avocana oui
bah ils ont une vingtaine de jours ah
bah oui oui d'accord ils sont arrivés à
quel âge à peu près ils sortent de l’œuf
ils arrivent ici ils sortent de l'oeuf
et en plus ils sont ils viennent de
Sallertaine la commune d'à côté à 3 km
alors on peut pas être plus près ah oui
il voyage pas en avion depuis les pays
où il y aurait des du local plus
possible vraiment local donc ça c'est
les premiers canins depuis le vide
sanitaire le site a été un an vide et ça
fait qu'un mois que vous avez qu'un mois
qu'on a recommencé élevé du canard et
comment vous êtes nul le coup pendant un
an avec les aides de l'État ils
assurances aussi il y a pas d'assurance
il y a pas d'assurance c'est qu'il a
fallu monter des dossiers auprès de des
services de l'étape elle a été
suffisante cette compensation tu sais
juste c'est juste juste pour vous
maintenir à flot c'est juste pour nous
maintenir à flot pour nous éviter de
fermer nous maintenir juste à flot
combien de canards ici là il y en a 2000
c'est 2000 canards là ils portent vos
espoirs de l'avenir
je porte l'espoir de mes collègues aussi
parce qu'il dit Dominique redémarre et
nous aussi on va vouloir redémarrer quoi
c'est c'est c'est parti quoi
[Musique]
voilà le clip pépère alors tu t'es fait
choper et vous constatez que c'est des
canards qui bien-être animal qui ne sont
pas débéqués ni des griffés
comme un canard de basse-cour quoi
tout dépend comment les élèves quoi ça
c'est comme un animal de compagnie si
vous voyez nerveux l'animal de compagnie
va être toujours été énervé tu vois les
filets sont là là
[Applaudissements]
on parle pas de magret on parle de filet
parce que ah oui oui parce que le magret
c'est sur le canard gras tout à fait
mais c'est la même partie c'est-à-dire
le dessous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je reviens de chez un éleveur de
canards chalandais ça a été une année
terrible pour Dominique il nous
expliquait qu'il a vécu du RSA ça a été
un drame ça a été un drame sur le plan
économique bien sûr mais c'était aussi
un drame une souffrance psychologique
énorme pour nos éleveurs parce que ils
ont vu leurs animaux qui ont dû être
rabatier et par millions et par million
et pour la France ça a été aussi un
drame parce que on a maintenant une
souveraineté alimentaire qui était
cornée
alors on a passé une journée ensemble
extraordinaire sur cette île de
Noirmoutier qui est quand même un petit
territoire presque tarsique on a
l'impression que ici on peut vivre
presque en locavore en loco-production
on a beaucoup parlé des produits locaux
ma séparés pour les hommes et les femmes
politiques
il faut pas construire des couleurs seul
on a besoin de Racine on n'est pas des
portes artificielles je suis venu à la
France par la Vendée par cette histoire
une histoire vendéenne une histoire
nationale mais moi je fais partie de
cette tribu des gens qui ont des racines
des gens qui savent d'où ils viennent et
qui savent peut-être mieux où ils ont
aussi quand on est de nulle part
c'est comme les produits vous savez on
perd de sa saveur voilà je crois qu'il
faut qu'une femme ou un homme politique
il est des convictions qui y croient
vraiment voilà on reconnaisse à ça il y
en a marre des produits standards
partout en politique comme ailleurs
merci beaucoup de cette visite
on a bien l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
manger vendéen c'était voter français
exactement c'est une bonne conclusion et
on se retrouvera évidemment bientôt sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat pour découvrir
toutes ces départements gourmands avec
toujours cette appétit de la France à
bientôt je voulais vous offrir une
médaille du cœur ça vient du coeur
vraiment merci beaucoup ça me fait
plaisir on paye nos patates avec de l'or
[Musique]
avec Mutualia la mutuelle des
territoires
[Musique]